when it comes to television shows there
are no shortage of mistakes some are so
small that you might not even notice
them when you're watching stay tuned to
find out which scenes in Jesse just
don't add up are you new around here
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more great content like this
now onto 10 mistakes and Jesse you might
have missed New York new nanny we all
know that jesse has been in our lives
for some times now but remember when the
show first came out it first aired all
the way back in 2011 you would think
that when the show first airs the
producers would do everything in their
power to make sure that it's perfect
it is after all the first time people
watched the show but apparently even
premiere episodes aren't free of error
just take Jesse's first episode new york
new nanny were introduced to Jesse who
moves to New York to live on her own and
be an actress at the beginning of the
episode when she can't pay the driver
she's thrown out of the cab this is
where the mistakes occur when jesse is
thrown out of the cab she's thrown from
a distance that is unreachable by the
driver he also somehow manages to throw
her bags out even though they were in
the trunk of the cab and he was inside
of the car despite these mistakes the
episode goes on and Jesse meets the Ross
family and has offered a job as their
nanny because the kids think that Jesse
is too demanding they run off in their
parents helicopter Jesse eventually
finds them and brings them back talk
about a crazy first day the talented mr.
Kipling the mistakes in season one just
keep on coming one of the episodes with
the most mistakes is the episode titled
the talented mr. Kipling
in the episode jesse has a nightmare
that a huge version of the kids pet
lizard mr. Kipling is attacking her when
she wakes up Mr Kipling is in her bed
Ravi says that maybe mr. Kipling got
into bed because he was bored in his
cage so Jesse decides to take the kids
to the park so Ravi can walk mr. Kipling
and Emma can work on her school project
with Luke on the way back from the park
mrs. Chesterfield sees mr. Kipling and
freaks out she calls him a vicious
cold-blooded reptile she then points out
that the reptiles are not allowed in the
building fast forward a bit and mr.
Kipling attacks mrs. Chesterfield
this causes the woman to do everything
that she can to get the lizard taken
away Jessie spends most of the episode
trying to fight for the pet to stay but
the mistake comes in when Jessie and the
kids
to the elevator to go to the park Zuri
isn't with them when they go to the
elevator but then when they get off of
the elevator Zuri is right there
how did she just magically appear like
that one day wanders in the episode one
day wanders Jessie is seen playing her
guitar in Central Park people notice and
begin giving her mind while she's
playing Luke joins in and they make a
lot more money
later in the episode JJ Mayfield who is
a big music producer sees Jessie and
Luke performing in the park and promises
that he will make them famous he even
gets them a studio to shoot a music
video in but then it is revealed that
Jessie and Luke will have to pay $1,200
to shoot the music video while filming
the video the two fight over the
spotlight which obviously causes issues
to come up between them while all of
this is happening Bertram gets Emma to
help him with his style for a social
media profile but it gets a little out
of hand when Bertram realizes that he
can edit the photos to make himself look
thinner he reveals that he only joined
social media to meet up with his old
high school crush but he takes the photo
editing a bit too far here is where the
mistakes come in when Emma takes
pictures of Bertram with her tablet her
fingers are covering the lens if that
were a real photo her fingers would have
ruined the photo and then when Bertram
opens his sweater Emma says that she
swallowed one of his buttons even though
the sweater uses a zipper get it
together guys make new friends but hide
the old now we're in season two maybe
you thought the errors would fall just
in the first season but that is not the
case at all the errors just keep on
coming and the episode titled make new
friends but hide the old it's the
beginning of a new school year on Emma's
first day of school she meets a girl
named Rosie Rosie is rude and aggressive
unfortunately she and Emma are assigned
to do an art project together of course
during the project Rosie ends up
embarrassing Emma while all of this is
going on Luke is having his own trouble
at school after his stuffed koala falls
out of his bag people begin bullying him
Ravi says that the Koala is his and
people start teasing him instead
Zuri is also having trouble because her
homework is more difficult than it's
ever been so she refuses to do it the
mistakes in this episode are all over
the place first
Zuri never actually gets in trouble for
not doing her homework and second when
Jessie and Zuri fight over her homework
she says that Zuri has to do her
vocabulary words but the sheet says that
it's
homework so which one is it 101 lizards
while we're on the topic of season 2
let's talk about the 101 lizards episode
as we all know Robbie is obsessed with
lizards so in this episode Robbie
finally realizes that he cannot properly
take care of all 12 of his lizards so
Jesse suggests that he puts them up for
adoption
Robbie then interviews potential lizard
owners but doesn't really like any of
them towards the end of the day a lady
named Cassandra is interviewed and says
that her boss will take the lizards to
live upstate in a loving home later
Jesse and Robbie find out that her boss
is actually mrs. Chesterfield if you
remember mrs. Chesterfield hates the
lizards Jesse and Robbie become
convinced that mrs. Chesterfield wants
to turn the lizards into accessories but
really she just wants to donate them to
a lizard sanctuary the error in this
episode could definitely go unnoticed if
you weren't paying attention when Robbie
says goodbye to his lizards pay
attention to the bags in Jesse's hands
when he gives Sanjay his bag there are
two in the tray but when he gives Mowgli
a bag there are five in the tray and
after that there's only one bag left it
just doesn't add up
caught purple handed throughout the show
jesse is always trying to keep the kids
in line so in the episode caught purple
handed she asks the kids why they didn't
turn the money in then they made from
selling muffins at school in order to
raise the money they were supposed to
make for delivering the muffins the kids
throw a party without telling Jesse they
lie about having a celebrity guest at
the party so that more people will show
up obviously they weren't able to get a
celebrity guest to come to the party so
instead Luke disguises himself and
pretends to be a celebrity
with all of this going on Jesse manages
to land an audition for a hand
commercial with her new agent
unfortunately she accidentally puts her
hands in purple paint and ends up
getting fired even though the job and it
horribly Jessie tells max that she'd
still like to continue working with him
the trouble with this episode comes from
when max was shooting footage of Jessie
in the park
the whole time he was supposedly
recording her the phone screen was on
the homepage now we aren't expert
filmmakers or anything but we're pretty
sure you can't film anything on the home
screen of a phone Jessie's Aloha
holidays with Parker and Joey you would
think that on crossover episodes that
production team would pay even closer
attention to the continuity of episodes
after all it is featuring two shows but
that is not the case at all in Jesse's
Aloha holidays with Parker and Joey
episode which was all
crossover with Liv and Maddie there were
plenty of errors
despite the errors the episode premiered
with three and a half million views
which isn't too shabby if you ask us
anyway in the episode Jessie and the
Ross kids head to Hawaii for a vacation
and Parker and Joey join them there's
one major goof in this episode that you
might have missed if you were not paying
attention when Emma first walks up to
the gift stand before the volcano
becomes active there's a flower in her
hair below her ear later the flower is
behind and above her ear Peyton lists
who plays Anna probably realized the
awkward placement of the flower in
between takes and moved it little things
like that definitely can throw off a
show she should have either just left
the flower where it was or they should
have refilmed the first part of the
scene with the flower in the right place
either way you can't switch things F way
through a scene good luck Jessie who
doesn't love a good crossover episode
crossovers usually bring some of our
favorite shows together
good luck Jessie brought together good
luck charlie and Jessie in the episode
teddy duncan from good luck charlie gets
accepted to a college in new york city
while she's there she and her brother PJ
meet Jessie and Zuri on the subway
unfortunately PJ and Teddy have to stay
in New York City for a little bit longer
than they had originally planned because
a blizzard hit the city while this is
going on the Ross kids find out that
someone stole their Christmas presents
and unless PJ and Teddy to help them
find out what happened back in Denver
where Teddy is from Bob and Amy work to
figure out what Charlie wants for
Christmas in the end it's Gabe who
figures out what Charlie wants it all as
well now for the mistakes in part two of
the episode Teddy and PJ's hair is a lot
different than it was in part one
Teddy's hair is suddenly dark blonde and
PJ's hair turns lighter this is probably
because the two parts were not shot at
the same time in fact part two was
probably shot after good luck Charlie
finished production completely talk
about a serious timing error for broke
kids we finally made it to season four
in the goofs man they just keep on
coming
just take a look at the for broke kids
episode as we all know the Ross kids are
completely loaded but in this episode
jesse has to tell the kids that their
parents have lost a lot of their money
because of this the kids have to think
of a way to earn more money during this
time mrs. Chesterfield moves into their
apartment and Tony is kind enough to let
Jessie and the Ross kids stay in his the
kids each set off to find a new way to
make money and end up really learning
the values of a
later Jesse tells the kids that the
government made a mistake and that they
actually haven't lost all of their money
at all in a strange turn of events it's
actually mrs. Chesterfield who ends up
losing all of her money due to some
illegal tax deductions that Robbie found
on her computer Tony asks her if she
wants to live with him but of course
mrs. Chesterfield is disgusted by the
idea the mistake in this episode is a
really weird one when Emma first asks
Jesse how being a handy woman is going
she's inside the snack shack if you pay
attention on the next cut she's standing
right next to Jessie weird
someone has to to pay who doesn't love
Bertram he's so grumpy all the time that
it's great to watch in the episode
someone has to to pay he tries to switch
things up a bit and buys a new toupee
for his performance with his band
unfortunately the hairpiece soon goes
missing Jessie asked each of the kids if
they've seen the toupee fun fact this
episode was part of Disney Channel's
whodunit weekend
the kids end up trying to help Bertram
said he will do good in his performance
even though Bertram is worried that his
fans will be upset that he has no hair
he still goes on and performs so we
guess all's well that ends well
well except for one major goof go back
and watch the part reserved tries to
help Jessie down from the tree at first
she has her hands on the tree and she is
shaking it but when Jessie falls her
hands are down and nowhere near the tree
did they film the scene in two takes
when they started filming the second
take that they just forget that Zuri was
shaking the tree branch in the first we
need answers Disney we need answers
that's it for 10 mistakes in Jessie you
might have missed did you notice any of
those mistakes and you were watching the
show let us know in the comments thanks
for watching bye e
[Music]